who is familiar with the cubes concept
and olab
here nice okay so I'm going to talk
about uh cubes the python lightweight
framework for uh multi-dimensional
modeling and actually building building
the
cubes and I have lot I have lot lots of
stuff to go through so it's going to be
kind of like lightning talk but a little
bit longer uh not going to dive into too
much details if you have questions then
we can look at particular feature of uh
of Cubes so most of the talks here are
about data analysis this is going to be
more about the understanding of the data
which actually the whole concept of the
cubes and multi-dimensional modeling uh
usually is about for those who haven't
seen cubes before it's
mainly its main purpose is to build
reporting apps or the modules for repor
reporting apps that are based on a on a
metadata model and for aggregation of
the data so it's very
simplified uh explanation of Cubes is a
mapping between The Logical view of the
data to a physical physical uh storage
of the data and the kind of data it
works the best is the category is the
categorical data it's basically
aggregation based on on categories so it
started as a as an Olaf
framework I rather call it a conceptual
modeling and analytics framework so the
original cubes before 1.0 1.0 was
released in September it was really
simple framework which had just one
model one data store one database and
one workspace per process or per server
so we wanted to have a multiple
databases you have to launch multiple
servers or multiple processes to access
all those different databases
and you would have to fit everything
into into one model so and we need
more cubes was redesigned because you
might have model even like written in a
in a file stored somewhere or the model
can be stored in database or there are
already services that have these concept
of cubes and why not use them why not
just read their metadata and translate
it to our view of the cubes model and to
our a perception of Dimensions from that
store and also on the other hand on the
bottom on the store side you might have
different databases you might even get
the data from an API and you would like
to present it in to the users so users
do not need to know where the data comes
from and the data are already expected
to be formatted in a certain uh usable
way so here comes the cubes
1.0 finally it's Python 3 and uh still
supported uh Cube still supports the
Python 2.7 for the two series but the
main focus is going to be on python
python 3 and here's the highlight of the
features I'm going to talk about so
first is analytical workspace uh model
provid
us how the new backend for the cubes uh
looks like how we Access Data how we can
extend the cubes and things like
authentication and
authorization so analytical workspace is
the biggest change in in cubes and this
is the place where you bind together
all your storage and all your parts of
your data vhouse
um together in in one space one works
space so in this example we have four
cubes two different databases one Cube
coming from external source and that
Source also provides the model so we are
not specifying the model we just read
the model from these external source for
example from the mix panel we just read
the properties of the cube from the mix
panel and present it as a cubes and
users do not have to know that it
actually comes from different
stores here's an example how you
configure such an
environment so we specify the list of
the models you specify the databases the
connections and the cubes framework does
the rest it Maps those models to
particular data source and retrieves the
data from that
store and well yeah you can bring your
own either beer or backand
and newbe
supports all the SQL databases that SQL
Alchemy supports SQL Alchemy is actually
really awesome
framework if you do not know about that
definitely recommend if you are working
with relational databases and uh this is
just a few of them listed I think there
are like around 10 and also others as
external models for the SQL Alchemy uh
the new backends for cubes in cubes 1.0
is the backand for the mongodb for mix
panel for Google analytics to also to
demonstrate how you are getting the
external
models for cubes and of course uh cubes
can connect to itself so if you have
different instances running over there
like or if you would like to present
just few cubes for open data server on
your for your users you just connect to
a cubes running in a different place and
present it as a part of your collection
of
Cubes so what is a new back end of Cubes
there are three kinds of objects in in
the back end and it's a model provider
the aggregation browser and the data
store and I'm going to explain all all
three so model provider well provides
the model either from from the file or
from external Source browse out the
aggregations and store is connected to
the database so let's have a look at
model provider in more more details and
I'm going to use Google analytics as an
example because really nice nice example
to
demonstrate how the model provider works
so if you are familiar with Google
analytics they have an API and they also
have a metadata API so you can already
retrieve the metadata about the metrix
inside and you can get Dimensions you
can get the
metrix and we are just going to
translate them to our way of modeling
the cubes so we are we load the data
from the from the Google API and create
this illusion of
cubes on on our
side so model
provider creates the the metadata on the
Fly not we do not even have to have the
specified list of the cubes
uh before we run the server every time
we are trying to get the data we get the
list of Cubes that's available for for
the user at that point occurring on the
on the server or external external
Source here's just an example of mapping
of the concepts so for example in in
cubes the fact is usually mapped to a
table dimension approximately to a
column might be multiple columns and
well obviously you need to define the
model because you do not have enough
metadata in a SQL in a relational
database to understand that you can try
to derive it but not always uh
sufficient in mongodb the cubes is cubes
is usually a collection and here you can
also see the Google analytics where we
are mapping the metric to a cube so for
Google analytics in our case we have one
Cube per metric or Illusion of a cube
per metric and dimension say say uh
dimensions so what are the model
improvements in cubes
1.0 um these are the basic three ones uh
first we have additional metadata and we
split the measures and Aggregates so
Aggregates are not no longer generated
implicitly from the list of measures you
you define them explicitly I will show
you how and more front and metadata to
be usable by by the reporting apps and
you can link the dimensions within the
context of the cube or so I'm going to
to to show it so the measure is the
property is is the numerical property of
the fact and aggregate is um well
aggregated aggregated measure so there
are like two separate pieces of uh
metadata also in in our
model and this is how we Define it in uh
in the model so no as I as I mentioned
before the aggregate names are no longer
generated so your front end doesn't have
to guess like oh is it going to be
called this way or that way uh you can
use to name whatever you want and it
also solves the problem of custom
labels for for the for the Aggregates
here yeah so the custom name can also
refer to other Aggregates you can even
do the computations on top of Aggregates
one once the Aggregates are are
retrieved from from from the database
you can use other post aggregation
function
to
get
different yeah you can use POS
aggregation
function so contextual Contex contextual
Dimensions it's you are linking a
dimension to a cube based on U on a
context so you might have a cube where
the granularity of a dimension for for
example the time might not be uh on an
hour basis or a daily basis but your
time Dimension is on hourly basis and
your fact table or fact table your cube
is on monthly basis so you just link the
dimension that already exist but you say
oh but I just want on the level on the
month level to link I just want to link
this dimension on on a month level there
are more properties that you can specify
for that that particular context in the
cubes more front end and backend also
related metadata are Dimension roles so
you can specify what role is this
Dimension currently there is only one
role is a time and you specified the
level which is like year month day or
week and then front ends can display the
most appropriate user interface for that
Dimension and also backhands
can work with that property in a special
way it if they know how to how to deal
with that another another
piece of metadata is cardinality so you
can specify the dimension cardinality or
a level cardinality which is also use on
the both sides it's used on on the front
end side and on the on the on the back
end side on the front end side we
usually using it to know what kind of
user interface you are going to display
for that Dimension or for that level so
if the dimension is of a high
cardinality you're not going to display
the all the values because you can kill
your web browser so you just use some
search field or something simpler to to
display that if it's tiny cardinality
you just display bunch of check
boxes and on the backhand side it's kind
of like prevention for users to kill
your database so they are trying to
drill down through a high cardinality
dimension you can just say no I'm not
going to do that because I'm going to
just sped lots of data you have to add
like
additional conditions fil
to that query and then I'm going to
answer so it's also kind of like
protection the browser so this is the
core which does the aggregations or
delegates the aggregations to another
external uh system so the browser uses
uses the model to understand how the
browser should generate a queries or how
should delegate the generation of
queries to other other uh
systems and gets the data and provides
the data to the
user here are the basic browser methods
pretty much the same you can aggregate
get the members of the dimension get
effects get that one particular fact get
can you can get the cell details cell
details are mostly used for the front
ends to generate these I call them
multi-dimensional bread Crums where
users see oh this is where I'm actually
looking at I'm looking at it this year
and this customer and the new method is
features it's just a metadata method
that will return turn what this browser
is able to provide what kind of
functionality this browser is providing
for this Cube you are asking for because
different backends might provide
different functionality and some
backends for example do not have the
facts do not have the details they just
provide Aggregates but I would like to
know what I can get for this CU for this
back end so this is the the the method
this is what this method is used for
another nice feature is a split Cell
It's kind of artificial Dimension that
it's being generated on a on a query
time and example use of the split cell
I'm looking at the year for example year
of 2014 and I would like to compare
first half of the year and second half
of the year so I Define the split cell
as a first half of the year and then I
will get the result split into two parts
the first part of the year and the
second part of the Year also using my
contextual
cell so it's artificially uh generated
uh Dimensions based on based on the
query might not work on all the backends
it's implementing in the SQL backend so
SQL backend you can you can use
that yeah so I say mentioning the post
aggregation uh once you get the
Aggregates they're mostly useful for
time series so when you're are drilling
down by
dates any level you can use the post
aggregation uh
functions the store there's not that
much to talk about the store it's it's
really simple doesn't provide yet that
much functionality uh mostly provides
the connection and multiple browsers can
share one connections with a store it
can communicate to external
ipis in the future it might provide
functionality like
validation it can
generate schemas might provide
optimization but not yet yet but it was
made a separate separate part of object
so this is my my uh favorite part is the
SQL back end or known as relational olab
or SQL query generator in cubes so this
is built-in uh backand in cubes it comes
with cubes already when you install
cubes you get a you get a SQL
backand well you get a backand as
well but this is the most most developed
one so what's new in in SQL backend
there is a new quer query Builder uh
joint optimization support for outer
joints which was slightly tricky but we
did it uh support for the split
Dimension as I was mentioning and new
aggregate functions so let's have a look
at at a joint optimization so if you are
if you're quering um really big
snowflake schema the cubes is not
denormalizing the whole snowflake schema
and then applying your drill Downs or
your cell condition
it figures out what attributes from
which tables are being used for that
particular query for that Snowflake and
it just joins the table that are
necessary for that query you are
asking which is I think nice because the
less joints you are having the faster
you can get your your uh answer so it
analyzes the query selects the tables
and
creates the
joints
here here had
the other joints so originally cubes did
just uh just an inner join so you had to
have the the records also in the fact
table and in the in in dimension tables
uh what was at it are are the outo joint
so for example if you are joining the
time Dimension you can
get the values the members from 10
Dimension that not necessarily have to
have the in the fact table
so this is called a I call it here um a
detail which
is one way and another way was edit it's
not recommended to use it but the second
case is where you are counting all the
facts in all the all the rows in the
fact table and for which you don't
necessarily have to have uh Dimension
Dimension uh members it's not
recommended because you should have your
Di mentioned cleaned up you should have
at least the values for the unknown or
missing values in there but since cubes
the target of your cubes are also
simpler users and not that clean up
databases we also provide this
feature I mean why not you can clean up
later meanwhile you can use uh this
feature another feature added is
authentication and
authorization there are some cases
mostly in in a businesses where we would
like to restrict the access to the cubes
where we would like to restrict for
example access for a manager to a
particular store data or you would like
to for agents to see only his data in
the cubes and you can limit it um by
adding these rules who can access what
portion of of the cube or which cubes
what what person can can access so
Authentication building a slice server
is highly extensible there is just very
simple authenticator in in a server and
authorization is build in in a workspace
so when you're quering the
workspace it asks the authorizer hey can
I uh can I query this Cube and if the
authorizer says yes you can query this
Cube but you have to add these
additional conditions for this user it
will just add the conditions will return
the modified cell and you just fire that
query to to to the
browser here is just an example of a of
a simple built-in authentication nothing
sophisticated you would like to some
something more sophisticated or sorted
data in uh in a database you can this is
just a simple file base authentication
here uh how you configure it you just
say use this simple and the rights are
in the rights uh
file you are you can build your own like
L auth authenication and author a like
both modules can be
customized and this is my second
favorite part is the slicer
server which was rebuilt using
flask and you will see the advantage of
using flask in in this case uh the model
queries were changed there is no longer
um whole model query because as I was
mentioning all these external sources it
might take forever to retrieve all the
cubes for the for the external sources
you might have like
60 cubes in mix panel because you have
six 60 different kinds of events on mix
panel and you do not want users to wait
that long to retrieve all these
information from Mi panel so you are
just getting the brief list of Cubes
which is just a name a label and basic
stuff you can display in
your selection box for the cubes and
then if you would like to know the more
details the structure of the dimensions
then you create a particular model for
that cube when user selects the cube you
just get the the whole description so
this is the reason why the model was
dropped from from the API of the
cubes uh the queries they are still the
same so we have the aggregate members
fact fact and cell for the for the
multi-dimensional
breadcrumbs
um it looks still the same that nothing
changed all the couple of features were
added so I was saying I was talking
about the split Dimension it was also
added and uh
the aggregation is the same the members
is the same so the server basically the
same you have to but but you have to
always specify explicitly the cube and
Cube Cube name in in the query the
response is also the same slightly
richer might contain more information
you can look it up in the documentation
what kind of information is included in
the in the
response uh just to mention it Al you
don't necessarily have to have the keys
of
Dimension as a numbers or as an
identifier as it was uh before now you
can have whatever you want you can query
any column because you can just simply
Escape The Columns uh in in a query this
is a nice feature for the for the end
users and also for for the front ends
this was added uh you can specify the
Rel relative time so you can say hey let
give me the just like last three months
or 90 days ago until today and this is
where the server is using the role of
the Dimension so we have the roll at
time then it can use these piece of
information it's nothing sophisticated
it's not
like complicated language passing it's a
really simple grammar but it serves its
purpose for the most of the cases that
people need that so just couple of
months days or whatever granularity you
would like to go back or
forward another thing that was added
more output formats so we get a CSV Json
and Json lines which is like line the
limit Jason for for the fs and and and
the
members and also for the
aggregation it's not there yet but the
Json L will be added also for
aggregation so this is this is one of
the reasons why it was also migrated to
flask it's the way of deployment how you
use how you can deploy the the
cubes so a couple of yoga positions here
uh I'm not going into details on all
these just you you can see that there
are many
ways how to deploy the cubes so for
example you can have a slice server
running and you write your application
just in HTML and JavaScript and
communicate through the Json with the
server or there are couple of open data
instances which are implemented in a way
as you can see on
the as you can see on the right side uh
right top side where is a slicer server
running and you have your app in
whatever language you want you just
connect to the server and display the
data and you can also integrate the
cubes in your application so if your
application is written in in a in ajango
you just call Direct you don't even have
to use the slicer you just call directly
the cubes uh methods or if your app is
written in flask and you would like to
provide like raw analytical data API you
can use use this nice feature is a flash
blueprint so you just use the cubes
blueprint and you will get the raw
analytical API for free basically for
your app immediately you just specify
the the route where it's going to be
rooted so the front
ends uh bunch of new front ends were
added generic browsing front ends for
the data were added to to the cubes or
are developed here is one really nice
one uh built by Robin Thomas and Ryan
berlu and this one is also included in
the in the cubes repo um you specify the
URL of your Cube server and the front
end is pure JavaScript and HTML it
connects to the server talks a little
bit with the server like what are the
cubes what are the models and then
presents to the user list of the cubes
in categories oh I I didn't mention the
categories you can also categorize the
the cubes it's a simple thing but for
the users is really important if you
have so many
cubes so you don't want the users to get
lost in in your number of Cubes they
specify how they would like to drill it
down and this is how it looks
like and you can select the graph it it
this one this application is mostly for
time series data so it's time series
oriented uh browsing application it can
connect to any 1.0 server so if you're
running you would like to see the data
you just connect with this app to the
server and you are ready to run your
reports before you develop your own or
if you are satisfied with this one which
is actually really nice and you can do
lots of stuff yeah you can change the
chart type you can change the filters
really nice the filter it has really
nice State time filter also using the
dimension roles if you have a dimension
Ro which is a date you can get nice
calendar browser so this is another one
again you specify the cube server the
location and you connect to through
another app this one is Cub Z developed
by Jose Juan Mones you can get it on on
on GitHub it has slightly different
approach it's more category oriented you
can generate multiple reports it has
this concept of panels where you see the
the the flow of your fault process
during during the reporting you can
display you can display the tables you
can display the charts and it's also
pure JavaScript and HTML but it also has
a jungle backhand where you can use to
save your reports share with other users
uh and so on so another nice uh generic
reporting app built on top of
cubes and there was uh a new app
released just a couple months ago it's
not generic but just to show you what
you can also do with with cubes is to
create an app for specific kind of
reporting and this is an open data
portal Czech Germany and frontend
developed by fix abet and data data
scraped and processed by one of the
leading open data experts freedrick
lindur you can get all all the all the
sources uh online but just to show you
this is another kind of application you
can build on top of uh cubes really is
just by the end of October or early
November so to sum it
up the new cubes 1.0 offers a
heterogeneous plugable environment it's
much easier to extend to write your own
backends WR your own model providers or
or or browsers
and the SQL query generator was hugely
improved there are lots of stuff I
didn't mention I didn't mentioned
localization how we can localize the
cubes and the metadata name spaces or
even like query logging and I also
didn't mention the incubated features
that are already in the Cubes but are
not
yet developed in a way that can be used
by anyone but they are already there for
the brain ones they can use them it's
like non- additive properties of of a
cube and there is also included model
app it's a Javascript app which allows
you to model the cubes it needs more
development and cubes JS which is a j
JavaScript library that connects to the
cube server it also needs a little bit
of more development to be used and
what's the future is
the I would like to include arithmetic
expressions in your model that will be
translated to either SQL or any other
backend you are using better SQL
improvements and I would like to use
couple of pogress features so if you're
using postr you can benefit even more by
using the cubes and slightly even better
API so it would be even easier to to
create a custom browser well and of
course uh Cub JS
but my capabilities JavaScript is not
that that good so if anyone knows
JavaScript he is welcome welcome to talk
to me and yeah I just with the help of
uh of Robin we created this simple
simple JavaScript
library but it yeah it needs to be
improved so cubes was never meant to
compete with big data all up Solutions
and I would like to keep it this way I
would like to keep the cubes uh still
lightweight so anyone can use it without
like 10
engineers anyone can just like spin off
instance of cubes on top of their not
always well model database and be ready
to run and build a front use the use
those reporting gaps on top of it if you
would like to contribute or use let me
know there is lots of stuff to improve
it grew quite a quite a bit so it's much
larger library but still trying to be
lightweight couple of credits here so
many thanks for having this
1.0 done and release to Robin Thomas who
developed quite a lot of features
including Monga backand Ryan berlu who
was working on the cubes visualizer
Josan Mones with his feedback and
improvements to cubes and his viewer and
Squarespace uh which contributed with
the open source release the open source
of their contributions to to cubes and
thanks also to to all the contributors
and uh people who commented on giab so
thank you and if you have any
[Applause]
questions which mean a tool
that
visual in SQL uh I haven't used that one
in
SQL
using yeah so this is actually this tool
for it's open source kind of tool for
doing that
arees well first is open source so
anyone can use it uh you can use it not
only on like SQL Server you can use it
on my SQL on pogress on Mango or like on
on anything and it's well it's
affordable people in world of open data
can use it uh they don't necessarily
have to like buy into huge uh BI
Solutions to be able to have the
features from the high-end BI
Solutions which most of the people don't
even need that much much they do not
even need that huge performance they
just need to have have their small
database running but have this nice
feature in there so Advantage is being
lightweight and being able to connect to
any homemade databases
cans no it's it has to be separate so in
in this case uh it's not
it's not computational engine it's not
like the whole data valous solution it's
not doing data integration it just
this cubes part that cubes are being
presented to to the users so it's not a
data integration solution if you would
like to mix the data together you will
have to either do it in in a separate
tool or uh different way
or in in in your data valous
so it's
yeah oh graph
database no no no graph
database but I would like to be
interested in description of the problem
just curious so we can talk about what
is the kind of
problem
okay thank
[Applause]
you